hello hi I'm giving a call back with a
line it's a security my name is how are
you today not too bad I got a call from
this number and I tried to call back and
it said something about security systems
I don't know right I guess I probably
either someone acquired more information
about the home security did you own your
home oh yeah I um I um
alright actually can you verify the code
yes
all right actually let's see here
did you have an alarm system in your
home or would it be at first time it be
my first time I don't have an alarm
system right now okay yep I did see we
give you a call let's say we run a
promotion on this area we're just
looking to gain some word-of-mouth
advertising arlynn and most employment
is to protect my homeowner's before
something happens because the sister
shows that every day there's over $18
reported breakings of home invasions so
I'm sure you could see the urgency and
protecting your home right yeah I mean
what where those numbers coming from um
it's kind of curious those those seem
pretty high yeah they pretty high are
pretty much the nationwide statistics
are yeah yeah this is like the census
sir I mean where's it coming from
I'm sorry there I said where those
numbers coming from I mean I could say
that like you know robberies are out 99
percent since like three weeks ago but I
mean if I don't have any way to verify
it
I'm just curious I mean it's not gonna
like take away from my willingness to
know that's not Tom sir I'm in a jacket
show where we got the certificates for
him but that is the daily number on the
numbers do change from time to time but
as the number this week that we come up
with over 18,000 a day so it's about 6
families every minute you know
experiencing a break-in hmm okay so I'm
sure you can see they're earning say
protecting your home right yeah
definitely so I'll be quick I'm just
gonna explain what's included with this
system and how we can protect your home
sounds good
goodness to me go ahead all right great
and the system they're providing it is
color touchscreen and Wireless it does
require a landline telephone you'll be
able to arm a disarm with the cell phone
and you could receive text notifications
when someone goes in and out your home
so worried about work through out of
town you're gonna
have the peace of mind to know what's
going on so well first put up your
keypad so you can arm and disarm your
system will protect all your doors with
wireless door sensors how many doors do
you have in your home that we need to
protect I only have two doors I have the
main front entrance door and the rear
exit were okay excellent I'll make a
note of that I'll also include the
motion sensor so even if someone tries
to break in using an out interval you
know your home is still secure yeah
is there any pets oh yeah I have a cat
so I'll make the system pet friendly for
you so you don't gotta worry about the
cat then or off well I mean my cat is
really kind of a like a jerk so I'm sure
you'll find some way to trip the system
or something like that but that's fun
well you cannot set the system up how
many pounds of the did you can't weigh
Mike Mike that's pretty hefty he's about
20 pounds okay great yeah he's a great
diet right so anything under 40 pounds
would not be able to set the system off
okay now at the rate that he eats food I
wouldn't be surprised if he reached
about 40 pounds now is that gonna be
kind of a problem because while he lays
down when he eats I'm gonna picture that
in your head like hat that sits in the
kitchen lays down and eats like imagine
if a human being did that that would be
astounding like if you went to a buffet
and a person just like pulled up a chair
and just started eating from the buffet
like that'd be astonishing it would be
and we'll also provided the yard signs
and window stickers just so we can't let
the intruder know that your home is
detected okay so your color touchscreen
system a professional installation will
all be at no cost to you the only
investment you're making would just be
in the monitoring service and that's it
and the service comes out to only forty
six dollars and ninety five cents a
month and that will be off so we'll
provide you with auto services and if
equipment out no clothes and all we ask
is after we make it happen itself some
friends about us okay now if it made you
happy is there any kind of like
top-of-the-line system because I want to
make sure my homes is protected as it
can be and if there is how much does
that normally run I mean for the
absolute best that you guys have
well we do have different packages our
next package up is a secure vision
it starts out $59.95 it does have a $99
installation cost I mean we provide you
with indoor cameras so that we can have
live video monitoring and your cell
phone laptop or your tablet is that
something that should be interested in
yeah I mean you know I've I'm frequently
on trips I'm usually out of the house
and I'm away and so I want to know that
at any point in time people can
physically see what's going on in my
home as opposed to you know just kind of
relying on some kind of a sensor to
activate or something like that um
what's the next step up for that well I
mean you can have we have a whole
complete all home automation micah
designer system that best fits your
lifestyle we can put in thermostat
control you can put door locks so you
can control it from anywhere across the
world correct and the only thing that
does require this high-speed internet
access in your home did you have
high-speed Internet yeah yeah I have a
have a pretty fast connection i mean i
have time warner cable's so how fast is
the internet really when you have time
warner cable but nonetheless like the
one thing that i'm the system sound good
they sound like really good deals but
the one question I have out of all this
is do any of them come with Tyrion
Lannister because I saw I said they
wouldn't even come with Tyrion Lannister
do you know what I'm talking about
you know what did that Tyrion Lannister
is it's it's can you pronounce it one
more time
I said Tyrion Lannister how do you spell
that
t Y or IO n and ymr yeah T y RI o in
time okay and the last part is La in end
is t o n no it's not right Lannister la
man ana es te r there we go IST ER i
don't know how to spell but yeah it's
it's Tyrion Lannister and the whole
reason I ask is because I just finished
the season finale of The Game of Thrones
and Tyrion Lannister killed his own dad
with a crossbow because his dad called
his girlfriend a [ __ ] you know during
Lannister I think is hands down the best
character
TV show and I think that most people
watch the show just for that like like
Peter Dinklage is amazing and like
everything he does and I'm really
thinking that if I'm gonna get a
security system in my home I wanted to
come with Tyrion Lannister because a guy
that's willing to kill his own dad
because he called his girlfriend a [ __ ]
that's the dude that I want that's
that's the guy that I want guarding my
home because that guy will kill anybody
for virtually anything and Ryo if
someone breaks into my home let's say
for example the security cameras fail
and the sensors don't activate for
whatever reason I don't know what maybe
it's weird this person's like you know
using Harry Potter magic and they come
busting into my home if Tyrion Lannister
just like smashes down the closet door
and he shows up with like a morning star
and a sword it's gonna scare the
absolute hell out of whoever it is
that's broken to me like they would
immediately run away and they would be
like ah you know and they would tell
like all their friends because I assume
there's like this inner group of like
burglars and stuff they all talk to each
other and they would be like don't break
into that dudes home because he's got
Tyrion Lannister garden that [ __ ] you
know either that or like a clown cuz
clowns are just creepy
but you know if it doesn't have either
one of those things I'm not really sure
that I'm interested in investing in the
security system because you know I just
wouldn't feel you know I would feel like
no matter where I went in the world if
Tyrion Lannister regarding my home it
would be safe from anything which
includes like dragons and Voldemort and
other stuff let me ask you a question
how much would you do we how much would
you be willing to invest to have a
Tyrion Lannister to protect your home
there's no cap on that price I mean you
know it's there's there's no there's no
upper limit to how much can you how much
can you afford to protect the home with
sorry I'm Lannister I mean you know I
would say at least probably 2,000
galleons I mean or whatever whatever it
well galleons is Harry Potter money I
remember what the money's called in the
game of Thrones but two thousand dollars
where the money is in Game of Thrones
two thousand a month yeah from from with
on the Thrones money this is Game of
Thrones money this isn't like our money
cuz our money's not as good as Game of
Thrones money so whatever mm
the Game of Thrones money is then that's
what I would pay Tyrion Lannister
per month to guard my home alright well
let me let me shot it let me do what I
can to get in contact with Peter
Dinklage and see what I can do to get
the Tyrion Lannister in front of your
home ok you are the man I appreciate it
sounds good take care buddy